I saw this story yesterday Bryan
Cranston and Aaron Paul the stars of
Breaking Bad are donating 30% of
proceeds of all online sales from their
tequila it's called us home raise and
that'll benefit the Cova 19 relief funds
in particular in United States
bartenders guild I believe through May
first did I get that right Brian kind of
you got a couple things wrong the fact
checker here okay all right that's why
I'm I'm good good buddy good to talk to
you good to talk to you too hope
everybody is well in and around your
your family both at work and home yep
they are I got I got a son in Singapore
which is a little nerve-racking but
other than that you know they're kind of
close to home oh man
I are not gonna Majan are you all set up
in LA at home and is your daughter there
yeah our daughter owns her own house
from doing so well in her young acting
career that she lives about two miles
from us so it's been it's a nice little
walk to go visit her been looking over
the fat she's self quarantined and we're
not able to associate with her so we
don't want to take any chances so are
you so bored that you're watching
Malcolm in the middle or Breaking Bad or
any of your movies I take umbrage to
that I would have to be bored in order
to watch those two fantastic series yeah
but most actors don't do that most
actors and you're one of the great
actors of our generation I didn't think
like I can't imagine DeNiro sitting
around watching taxi driver
no okay what would you watch Breaking
Bad or Malcolm in the Middle
if you had to pick between a show to
watch depends on my mood er sometimes
I'm gonna if I'm down I want to have a
comedy if I'm if I need to get serious i
watch Breaking Bad but you know I mean
been watching the tiger King that that
thing is
ridiculous we went through it in two
days what do you watch I'm wondering if
actors watch that and go what role would
I play or could I see that as a movie or
do you think that at all or did was it
purely entertainment it was just purely
entertainment to me and then all of a
sudden became real because apparently
and this is a scope they're going to do
the movie version of this at some point
and I'm thinking wow I don't know if
that would work how can you make the the
scripted version of Tiger King more
explosive or bizarre or interesting or
compelling to watch than the real thing
you can't you can't because nothing
replaces reality like when you go I
can't believe what I watch that I
thought it was if you said Christopher
Guest and you know the guy who gave us
Best in Show and waiting for Guffman if
you said Christopher guest's just
produced this to make it seem like it's
a mockumentary I would have bought it I
like this is the feeling I watched when
I was watching yeah it was pretty
jaw-dropping and I you know some things
you shouldn't remake it I don't I don't
I think I'd stay away from that it that
you know for for reasons of becoming a
scripted filmed version I don't know I
don't I don't think that's a great idea
so you're not interested in being in the
movie no okay no okay I think I think
hands off you know I once was offered to
do the Scarecrow in a play version of
Wizard of Oz and I thought oh my God how
fantastic it's so indelible it's such a
great role and I was younger then and I
can flop around the stage and be goofy
and funny and and then I thought about
it and I realized this is a trap that
you would have to do exactly what ray
Bolger did in the movie or people would
go that's not the scarecrow what is he
doing he's not that
what he would do that's not how he acts
that's not how he sounds so you are
trapped and I think this in in a much
lesser version is the same thing that
how how can you match what performances
we saw in in Tiger King I don't think
you can we're talking to Bryan Cranston
star Breaking Bad and Malcolm in the
Middle and Broadway and movies and and I
truly believe one of the great actors if
not the best actor of our generation no
I really believe that you okay so tell
me all the things that I screwed up on
the introduction okay okay so dos
hombres is a mess Cal it's not a tequila
oh it's a miscount now all tequila's are
mezcals but not all moscow's are tequila
how should I drink those hombres yeah
well I would drink it neat with maybe a
little slice of orange you can make a
bite of and take a sip that's great it
goes great with with any kind of fruit
juice primarily you know tangerine juice
or or
mango or pineapple it's really delicious
I put it in a margarita instead of
tequila because it has as a little smoky
goodness to it but not too much it's
really terrific and and you and Aaron's
all came up with this like dude was this
while you were doing Breaking Bad or
after it was about six years believe it
or not six years after yeah about that
after we were done with Breaking Bad and
we said you know what let's let's do
something because we can't work together
as actors for a while so let's let's get
this together and do something he was
the one who brought it to my attention
we should start a Miss Calcutta and I
went are you crazy
didn't the spirits business I don't know
anything about it but it was it was
intriguing enough for us to go down to
Oaxaca and in do investigations and and
we were perfectly willing not to do it
if we didn't find the perfect
and we found it just by luck we found
this we named it those hombres two guys
just two guys doing you know doing
something that we're very proud of and
now you know yeah we have we have
employees that for the company now that
we have we were that are still on
payroll and we want to keep that going
but on the other hand where our hearts
are breaking to seeing what's happening
you know to to my second home in New
York there and all around the world and
and so Aaron and I were talking and I
said now's the time we just got to do
something and we agreed and at first it
was 30 percent to the to the bartenders
Guild Relief Fund which Ryan Reynolds it
was Ryan Reynolds idea and we said
that's a great idea let's do it at him
with his aviation gin and Tito's is on
board too so 30% of all the proceeds
that we make online sales because
there's no sales and bars and
restaurants now so 30% goes that then we
extended it for so from now until May
5th Cinco de Mexico we call it we are
giving a hundred percent of the proceeds
everything above our basic cost is going
to three different causes one still
going to the bartenders relief guild the
second one is going to the hospitality
relief fund which helps other people
waiters barbacks dishwashers people who
are in the service industry and helping
and doing such great work completely
shut off from able to make any money and
the last thing is the the American food
fund and that was started by Leonardo
DiCaprio and a great organization that
just churns out a hundred thousand meals
a day and they're just for people who
need food so
percent split three ways of every online
sales from Bill sombras at dos hombres
com goes to those three causes through
May 5th so stock up by your dos hombres
and and and you know that that money is
going to them and we'll look forward to
making an announcement how much we were
able to put together and send their way
when's the last time you were drunk
god it's been it's been a long time
maybe 20 years when's the last time you
had to act drunk in a role Oh
maybe 20 days ago yeah wait are you
working now I just you know we had to
shut down I was doing a limited series
in New Orleans called your honor for
Showtime and we shut down about four
weeks ago now and we have still a couple
more episodes of that to finish before
we're all wrapped up and in the can so
at some point we're going to go back
down to New Orleans and and finish that
but yeah it's just and you know that's
another cause that came to my attention
is all of our our crew being completely
shut down as well I mean there's so many
people who are hurting right now and I
can't I be I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't thinking about how fortunate I
have been in my career and that I'm
financially secure and it's time to help
those who aren't man it's really time to
step up do you have a man cave at the
house I have my office which is in a
dark deep red redwood lots of wood lots
and lots of wood
some metal in there to some trophies and
things that we shoved in there because
we're not showing people so we don't
want to put it out out in in the other
parts of the house so I kind of shove
them on shelves there and and I got my
comfy chair I got my TV and you know I'm
jonesing now because we're like it's so
weird to wake up and and look at the
feeds of the sports outlets and go
nothing going on today no and then all
you're reading is on this day twenty
years ago
hey I made a show out of that everything
tape hey stop I got to fill three hours
Brian you were doing like an hour at a
time when you did a show come on I know
compared to what you guys are doing now
I I feel for you they were lucky oh and
we're lucky that we're able to do this
and I people keep asking hey what are
you talking about I said there's so much
to talk about you know it's just it's
not games but then you it forces you to
be creative in what are you going to
talk about and who are you going to have
on it's like I can have you on and I can
have Hank Aaron on and Jack Nicklaus on
all in the same week and it works
because that's the show but you're also
interesting people and that's what I try
to point out if we have somebody on
hopefully you'll buy into you trust me
that we have somebody that you'll be
interested in and like Nicholas I've won
the Masters before and like Aaron I've
hit over 500 home runs
no that's the tie-in yeah that's how it
connects one of the great athletes of
all time and a pretty good actor it
sounds like if you're bored Brian it
next week like if you want to call in
because I really feel like you and your
wife have run out of things to talk
about and if you wanted to like if you
just want to talk like it's okay can I
can i it can it be like a therapy
session yes I can help
lay on my couch and just turn us free
they'll be riveting radio I'll be more
than happy to help questions you'll be
more than happy to help you give the
website give the website I got it it's
dos hombres dot-com dos hombres deles
hombres hom bo yes dot-com order today
100% of the proceeds goes to those three
really wonderful charities and as soon
as I get off I'm going to order bottles
for you and mold the Danette oh you
buried the lead I was waiting like I was
gonna how long did I have to have you on
before you were gonna send us some
mascara and those ombre them and my
friend yeah it's coming somebody's on
the way I'll send you a picture once we
get it perfect
hey great to talk to you as always but
thanks very well that all right thank
you Brian that's Brian Cranston